مرحبا انا محمد مزيما لنتابع معا ابرز
اخبار الاسبوع الماضي بايجاز وضمن ابرز
الاحداث تصعيد في غزه ورد من المقاومه
ترقب قبل بدء الانتخابات التركيه عام على
اغتيال شيرين ابو عاقله هل يذهب ميسي
للهلال السعودي اضافه الى اخبار اخرى
نتابعها مع بعض
تصعد اسرائيلي في غزه ورد صاروخي من
المقاومه هذا هو العنوان العريض للتطورات
التي تشهدها الاراضي الفلسطينيه خلال
الاسبوعيه الماضيه ولكن ما التفاصيل معي
الان الزميل صهيب العصا مرحبا صهيب
الاراضي الفلسطينيه تشتعل ما الذي يحدث ما
الذي يحدث ان اسرائيل اخترقت الهدنه
المعلنه بين قطاع غزه وبين الجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي واستهدف الثلاثه من قاده سرايا
القدس الجناح المسلح لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي بشكل مفاجئ ومباغت فجره الثلاثاء
بعد اكثر من 24 ساعه انتظرت المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لتبدا عمليه الرد وكان ذلك
مربا لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وللمستوطنين في غلاف غزه الصواريخ
الفلسطينيه وصلت الى جنوب تل ابيب نتحدث
عن 60 كيلومتر تقريبا والى غرب القدس
بطبيعه الحال نتحدث ايضا عن خمسه
ولكن في الاستهدافات بطبيعه الحال
مستوطنات غلاف غزه كانت التي اخذت النصيب
الاكبر من عمليات الاستهداف التي صوا
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ولكن هذه العمليه
يبدو انها مستمره مع انهيار محادثات
الهدنه في اكثر من جوله واكثر من وسيط
تدخل على الامر ولكن لا يبدو حتى هذه
اللحظه ان الهدنه تلوح في الافق ولكن
القتال يبدو متواصلا مع استمرار
الاستهدافات الاسرائيليه لقاده اسرائيل
سته من قاده سرايا القدس استشهدوا حتى هذه
اللحظه في الهجمات الاسرائيليه شكرا جزيلا
لك صهيب العصا بتاكيد انت في اطار الاعداد
لتغطيه المستمره على الجزيره من فلسطين
الى تركيا التي تشهد استقطابا غير مسبوق
مع اقتراب الانتخابات هناك اذهب الان الى
الزميل جلال شهد الموجود لتغطيه هذه
الانتخابات المهمه مرحبا جلال
كيف يبدو المشهد عندك حاله من الترقب محمد
خيمت على المشهد السياسي التركي خلال
الاسبوع الماضي مع تكثيف المرشحين
تحركاتهم قبل دخول مرحله الصمت الانتخابي
حيز التنفيذ عشيه يوم الاقتراح في تطور
لافت انسحب رئيس حزب البلد محرم انجي من
المنافسه قبل ثلاثه ايام فقط من يوم
التصويت قرار وصفه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
بالمحزن اما مرشح تحالف الشعب المعارض
كمال كريستار اوغلو فقد دعا انجي للانضمام
الى ما سماها طاوله تركيا المشهد لم يخلو
ايضا محمد من اتهامات بالتدخل بالانتخابات
وجهها كمال كريشتار اوغلو لموسكو مؤكدا
الوقوفها وراء فيديو يشوه سمعه مرشحي
الرئاسه الامر الذي رفضه
يعطيك العافيه جلال شكرا
بعد غياب لاحد عشر عاما مجلس جامعه الدول
العربيه اعلنت استانف مشاركه وفود سوريا
في اجتماعات مجلس الجامعه وجميع الاجهزه
التابعه لها قطر قالت ان موقفها من
التطبيع مع نظام السوري لم يتغير في حين
شككت واشنطن في رغبه بشر الاسد بحل الازمه
السوريه عوده سوريا الى الجامعه العربيه
اثارت جدلا واسعا بين النشطاء السوريين
لنلقي نظره على بعض تفاعلاتكم اسامه
الشامي يقول واتفق العرب على ان يتفقوا
ويجنحوا الى بشار ليشاركوا في انتاج اجزاء
جديده من مسلسل خذلان الشعب السوري
متجاهلين جرائم عمرها 12 عاما كانت السبب
في طرد نظامه من الجامعه في حين نتساءل
احمد الحمود في تغريدته قائلا ماذا قدمت
الجامعه العربيه للثوره السوريه
خجوله لا فعاليه لها وقوانين من امريكا
والدول الغربيه لا نفع منها كلهم لا
يريدون محاسبا من دمشق الى الخرطوم
وتطورات الحرب بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع اذ وقع الطرفان بالتعاون مع
السعوديه والولايات المتحده اعلان جدا
للالتزام بحمايه المدنيين في السودان
واتفقا على الالتزام بسياده السودان
والحفاظ على وحدته فضلا عن تسهيل المرور
الامن للمدنيين من مناطق المعارك منظمات
عده رحبت بالاتفاق ودعت الى ان يكون ذلك
منطلقا لوقف دائم للقتال معي من الخرطوم
مراسل الجزيره الطاهر المرضي
مرحبا الطاهر
كيف سيكون اثر هذا الاتفاق على الارض شكل
اعلان جد الموقع بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع باريقه امل للسودانيين
للحفاظ على ارواحهم وممتلكاتهم خاصه ان
الاعلان الدعاء الى سحب المظاهر العسكريه
من مواقع الخدمات كالمياه والكهرباء
والمستشفيات وايضا مثلا لبنه اساسيه بوجهه
نظر الكثيرين لحل جذري لهذه الازمه على
الرغم من ان هذا الاعلان لم يتضمن وقفا
لاطلاق النار ولكنه دع الاحترام القانون
الدولي لحقوق الانسان في مثل هذه الظروف
التي يمر بها السودان ومنع او وجه
المتحاربين من
الاقتتال في اماكن السكن ومنع ايضا كذلك
اقامه الارتكازات التي يمكن ان تؤدي الى
اعاقه حرقه حركه المواطنين والتنقل من
مواقع الاشتباكات الى الامنه يديك العافيه
الطاهر بالتزامن مع الذكرى السنويه الاولى
الاغتيال الزميله شيرين ابو عاقله برصاصه
الاحتلال اداره شبكه الجزيره تجدد تعهدها
بانها لن تدخر جهدا لتحقيق العداله
ومحاسبه القتله مؤكده انها ستتابع قضيتها
في المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه كما تم في
رام الله وضعوا حجر الاساس لمتحف شيرين
ابو عاقله للاعلام تكريما للزميله الرحله
ليس سهلا ربما ان اغير الواقع لكنني على
الاقل كنت قادره على ايصال ذلك
الصوت انا شيرين
ابو عقله نختم اخبرنا هذا الاسبوع بميسي
وجدل انتقاله الى الدوري السعودي اذ قالت
صحيفه تيليجراف البريطانيه ميسي قد ينتقل
الى الهلال السعودي بعقد مقابل 400 مليون
دولار سنويا حتى يونيو 2025 في حين كشفت
وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه ان صفقه انتقال
ميسي الى الهلال قد تمت بالفعل في المقابل
نفى والد النجم الارجنتيني ووكيل اعماله
هذه الانتاج شاركونا ارائكم هل يا ترى
سنشهد مواجهه بين ميسي ورونالدو في الدوري
السعودي
عن نفسي ارى ان ذلك سيكون مثيرا فعلا بدا
نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايته الاسبوعين نلتقي
بكم الاسبوع المقبل بحول الله اينما كنتم
طابت اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]